Do you ever wonder how your rates are spent?
Rates vary across the district depending on
services offered in your area, however on
average each day a resident will pay $7.33
in rates.
So where does that money go?
$1.40 a day is spent on our roads and footpaths.
.31c is spent on waste collection and disposal.
.46c goes towards the running of our district’s
libraries.
And 27c helps build and maintain our community
buildings.
15c a day is used for health and safety -
things like animal control, building consents and cemeteries.
73c is required for planning, governance and
administration costs.
Things like Civil Defence, District Development
and Council meetings
26c is for other.
Miscellaneous costs such as promoting our district’s
economic development
and contributing towards the Canterbury Museum.
39c is assigned to our swimming pools and
aquatic facilities.
While 17c assists with our ongoing earthquake
recovery.
1.39c looks after our waterways, storm water
drains and provides safe, clean drinking water.
It costs another $1 to deal with the sewage.
Leaving 80c a day to maintain our parks, reserves
and sportsgrounds.
So thank you for playing your part in building
and maintaining
the wonderful Waimakariri District